well let's get more on this now joining
me it now is Richard Barrett who's
former director of global
counter-terrorism operations at MI6 a
very good evening to you Richard Barrett
thanks so much for joining us so shamima
Bagan has lost her bid to regain her
British citizenship today what's your
reaction to that
well I'm disappointed for her and I'm
disappointed that the sayak the
commission
was not able to take into account all
the other factors of this case I mean
they just looked at it from the point of
view have had the Home Secretary then
Home Secretary acted lawfully not
whether his decision was right or not
and myself I think the decision was
wrong I think if it was made on National
Security grounds there are all sorts of
other aspects of National Security that
would have mitigated against his
deprivation of her citizenship and that
of course is a particularly Draconian
measure because
um first of all she was a child when she
left the UK second she hasn't had a
chance to argue her case in court
and and and third you know she's stuck
now in some sort of limbo without any
Prospect of returning to her family no
really of being a free woman she's only
23 she's got a lot of her life left and
she's stuck in a camp in Northeast Syria
which is not particularly safe place to
be for anybody let alone a woman of that
age
um and where does she go what happens to
her that camp is a temporary campus
certainly not going to last for very
many more years
and whose responsibility responsibility
is it to think of her future look after
her if you like
um if not her country of citizenship
country of birth and Country of
residence which is the UK well the
commission
and they that although there was
credible suspicion at the bacon was
traffic for sexual exploitation they
said that was insufficient for the
commission to Dean the home secretary's
decision unlawful and they said
essentially it was up to the Home
Secretary to decide what was in the
public interest essentially saying it
was up to politicians on the advice of
Security Services rather than lawyers
yes indeed that's a shame isn't it I
mean that is the conclusion they came to
and the conclusion that's born really of
a previous appeal by shamima bacon which
was which she lost and uh the Supreme
went to Supreme Court who effectively
gave the Secretary of State those powers
that on grounds of National Security he
could really make the decision and and
and leave it unchallenged
um so it's it is a question I think we
have to ask ourselves as the general
public uh well what on What basis did he
make this decision can we know more
about it and can we understand why this
young woman was such a almost
existential threat to the UK well yes I
mean you're a former director of global
terrorism operations at MI6 what's your
view on how much of a threat she might
be given that she did leave the country
to join a terrorist organization
yeah well since holding that position
I've spent a long time over 12 years the
United Nations dealing with these
terrorist issues I'm talking to very
many countries about how to cope with
radicalization how to promote the
radicalization and how to undermine the
terrorist appeal and I think that
depriving her of her citizenship and
banning her from coming back to her
country that I think everyone would
agree is her is her you know National
base rather than Bangladesh even if she
has a right to bank that she's
citizenship I think everybody would
agree that doing that
feeds a narrative that's put out by
terrorists that people of her ethnic
origin people of her faith are not
really welcome in Western countries that
somehow their second class citizens and
I think that's a very dangerous threat
to National Security actually
um let alone the individual threat that
any person who supports the Islamic
State might might pose
what are the implications of this
decision do you think does it set a
precedent for for other British
Nationals or dual Nationals who are
currently in refugee camps
well yes of course it does but again I
would say that the commission was
looking at this case on very narrow
grounds indeed see actually was the
decision lawfully made not whether it
was a good decision or not and I hope
that in future cases there might be much
more deference to the
um appellant if you like as to the
reasons they went the reasons they
stayed and the threat they may pose at
the moment rather than just accepting
a rather quick decision by the secretary
of state that the National Security
interests was best served in in stopping
these people come back okay well Richard
Barrett we appreciate your views tonight
thanks very much indeed for sharing them
with us
sure